[Music]
sarah's with us hi sarah how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
all right so my husband and i having a
baby in september and we're disagreeing
about whether or not we should be buying
a new to us car to prepare
we currently have a 98 honda accord and
a 2008 toyota rav4
i'm not really comfortable with the idea
of the baby being in the 98 all the
safety changes you know in the past
20 plus years
so we have no debt we make 180 000 a
year before taxes we have forty thousand
dollars outside of our emergency fund
um my husband acknowledges that we can
afford the car but doesn't want to buy
it because it's a want not a need it's a
bad time to be buying cars and there's
nothing wrong with the 98 um i think
we're ready for an upgrade
so what do you think can i or
better yet you tell him that it's time
to crack open his wallet
is he listening great you're awesome we
should sell tickets i think we should
sell tickets this is great
he's outside the room dave he's he's
standing with baited breath
[Laughter]
and he let you set all of this up just
to have his head taken off this is
awesome yes he did give me his arguments
before i called
his financial arguments are all accurate
um but there are some things beyond the
financial argument your argument on
safety is absolute bs it's absolutely
not true
okay you're talking to an old man that
grew up we wrote in the back window of
the car and they slammed on the brakes
it threw us into the floorboards so your
baby's gonna survive okay so it's gonna
be okay you're gonna be all right but
you can afford a car
so it is a want and you have the money
for the want it is not a need and
there's never been a car well except for
classic cars that are collectibles that
is a good investment they all go down in
value they're all mathematically
horrible
okay so it's just simply consumption but
you make how much 160 000 a year
180 twenty four taxes yeah sorry 180
okay
that's after tax
before tax well before tax 180 right
okay is that what you said
all right and you have 40 000 allocated
to the car
and you don't have any debt
right yeah okay
so uh you if you pay cash for the car
uh yes you should move up in car no you
should not buy a brand new car unless
you have a net worth of a million
dollars or more
in which case if you want to buy a new
car you can't i'm hard to find one for
40 but these days but you can do that
so but yeah i think you would move up in
car and uh you might move up in two cars
i'm okay neither one of these cars yeah
either one of these cars
but as long as you're paying cash and
the total that you're investing in them
is less than half of your annual income
and it would be
you know you wouldn't have the cash to
do more so um
you know but if you moved up uh 15 000
each in two different cars you would
move into substantially different
vehicles
um
and
we could just set the whole baby thing
aside except that that your pregnancy is
what caused the argument but
you just without a baby involved you
could still do this deal
it's not unreasonable financially
okay okay so you win the argument but
for none of the reasons that you thought
now sarah
sarah relationally i feel like i got to
speak up on behalf of your husband now
when you share this with him you got to
read him so maybe the win for you
relationally
with him is that you give him your car
instead of buying two cars that may be
too much for him to handle i don't know
dave this guy's on the other side of the
wall
ken is saying
that doesn't work to bring this up yes
i'm basically going uh i'll tell you
what we could just upgrade my car and
i'll give you
uh the one that i'm driving uh or maybe
if he wants you know you know the truth
is that his arguments financially are
all correct yeah
there's there's almost no time you can
justify
moving up in car financially
it almost never makes sense financially
oh it breaks down all the time it
doesn't break down as much as fifteen
thousand dollars which we're talking
about moving up on one car here right
you know fifteen thousand dollars in
repairs that's absolute bs and the
safety of a honda accord this one is
just fine you're just fine just don't
drive like a maniac you're not yeah but
you know it's not a james bond movie
you're in you're just taking a kid to
daycare so uh but the uh you know so
yeah but uh
but the truth is it's a luxury
that is not going to [ __ ] you
financially that you can afford
and i do some stuff like that and i'm
freaking dave ramsey which is kind of
synonymous with tight watts so
um you know i i sharon and i buy some
things that we can afford
and uh they don't meaning they can't
they don't [ __ ] us financially they
don't slow us down financially it's a
small enough number that it doesn't
matter and all of these numbers
fall in that category i'll tell you one
your coffee maker at the lake i have no
idea what it costs nobody's business but
that's a fantastic coffee maker but i
got to tell you at the lake house very
fancy i was intimidated by cars cheaper
yeah
see i didn't know but i'm going to tell
you we were i mean but i had some cheap
cars but yeah i mean
it's not a fifteen thousand dollar
coffee maker but yeah it's a nice coffee
maker is all i'm saying and it's just
you know it falls under the category of
sws sharon wants it ah i like it that's
a good category we can uh and in this
case uh sarah wants it swi right
so that would make great reality tv the
rest of this conversation see we put
sarah on hold now she's going to go talk
to the hubs who's behind the wall
watching how that goes
i told you so it's not going to be a
great line here but the uh because you
for all the reasons she wanted to do it
she was wrong
that's true the only reason it works is
because it works and you can afford it
and so if you want to buy an item
that doesn't make sense financially but
you have the money now here's another
way to look at having the money i often
use this on the air and i'll use it with
this case okay cars are the same way
if you take that amount of money and set
fire to it yes
just to watch it burn
does it hold you back substantially
financially does it cause you to walk
with a limp financially does it cause
you to be you know to be off your kilter
and if the answer is no then you can
afford yeah the luxury of it but
oftentimes people buy something and they
justify their butts off they rationalize
their butts off and it's something you
really that's the amount of money you
can't afford to burn up correct i mean
if you make sixty thousand dollars a
year and you wanna go buy a forty
thousand dollar car you can't afford to
burn that much money yeah it'll burn
your hair off i mean you can't do it
right and so that that's what the type
of way you're looking at is you go does
this change my life if i burn this much
money
then you go well then i can afford to
buy the luxury or you know like james he
collects he collects uh 25 000 guitars
right and i just made that up but he
does quick he has he's just choked he
does have way too many guitars there's a
lot of guitars represented in the booth
as a matter of fact that's true a lot of
stringed instruments are represented in
the booth can they afford those given
that none of them make their living with
those instruments
yes they can right because that amount
of money
as a luxury or in a hobby is something i
care about yeah doesn't something they
care about yeah i don't but they that
that's i mean if i buy this if i buy
another gun
like i don't have enough i got plenty if
i buy another one which i'm out to do at
any moment yeah does it change my
financial trajectory no yeah and as long
as that's the answer and if my wife buys
a purse no one should spin yet on a
purse you're right they shouldn't but
people do including her
and so
yeah no one should spend that on again
let me tell you what the let me tell you
what guns cost you two purses i was
getting ready to ask that you get a new
gun sharon gets a couple purses that's
good it's a trade out it's a trailer
same same with james and his guitars
right by the way when he says a lot of
guns if the tennessee tennessee national
guard had a shortage you're on speed
dial i know i'm gonna someday i'm gonna
be arrested as a as an insurgent
but the uh i'm not sure against what
hush you're gonna give people ideas
they've been looking for an end for you
there it
but the point being if you're spending
money on something that has absolutely
no
uh
benefit except it's something you want
you lit you have lived like no one else
so now you can live great and give like
no one else same thing about giving
money away
when you're being generous with the
money you should be able to give it away
and it not change your life except for
the huge benefit that being a generous
person gives you
it's the same exact process so but if
you want to give everything you own away
please stop and think about that one
that needs to be god's voice in your ear
for sure not some kind of guilt trip by
a liberal
this is the ramsay show